Speaker 1: Ron DeSantis, who spoke at CPAC
last year, has two events in Texas as CPAC
will be underway in Maryland.
A spokesperson for CPAC told ABC News neither
Pence nor DeSantis are currently slated to
attend.
DeSantis spokesperson didn't respond and Pence
didn't attend in 2022 and declined to attend
in 2021.
The context here is also believed to be the
sexual assault scandal.
Trump is scheduled to headline the event.
So I think that this is actually, you know,
normally CPAC is kind of a waste and I don't
typically cover much of it, if any.
Sometimes we've not covered any of it live.
My goal this year was actually to cover the
major speeches live on YouTube, Twitch and
Facebook.
Again, because of the interest that I have
in seeing how CPAC frames the 2024 Republican
primary.
Now, one of the things that may happen by
default is there are with the Santos and Pence
as possible 2024 Republican candidates snubbing
the event and Trump going CPAC may just default
to will praise the hand that feeds us.
Trump is coming here to speak, so we will
just get behind Trump, but we don't yet have
the full agenda.
I hope it will be released soon and we will
see what the coverage is from Fox News.
We will see what the attitude is towards the
primary.
I'm actually as interested as I've ever been
in covering a PAC, which is not typically
the case.
Ron DeSantis, who has not yet announced that
he is running in 2024, will not be at CPAC.
But he was interviewed last night by Fox News's
Mark Levin.
Now we're going to look at clips of the interview.
The interview was completely deranged and
delusional.
It's not clear who's more deranged and delusional.
Is it Ron DeSantis or is it the host, Mark
Levin?
But just for a little bit of context.
Mark Levin has a weekly show on Fox News.
And there's always these storylines that develop
in media outlets, these sort of cults of personality
or storylines that are that are used among
different people.
The storyline about Mark Levin is that he's
the more serious guy.
He is a legal scholar and he writes closer
to what we might call real books.
And he's so busy being an adult that he only
hosts a weekly show on Fox News because he's
really serious.
And so when you sit down with Mark Levin and
you've got the dark lighting, as you can see,
if you're watching everything about it is
this is a serious interview with a serious
person.
And if you're so serious that you can be interviewed
by Mark Levin, you must also be a very serious
person.
It's all a joke.
It's all it's all just complete and total
nonsense.
And Mark Levin is a bomb thrower, partizan
bomb thrower, just like everybody else spreads
disinformation.
It's just a story that they make up.
But understand that's the context.
Ron DeSantis is a very important deep thinker,
and so he's going to come in and have a serious
conversation with Mark Levin, starting with
talking about the woke.
And again, the framing here is they interview
DeSantis as if he's already running for national
office.
He's the governor of Florida.
Don't forget, he's the governor of Florida.
But the context and the framing of the questions
and the topics are this is a guy who should
be on the national stage and has a lot to
say about national politics, starting with
talking about the woke.
Speaker 2: And yes, you do have to fight the
woke in the halls of government and right
out of chambers.
Right.
We have supermajorities as Republican supporters,
so we will win all those fights.
But you also have to be willing to defend
your folks against this agenda being shoved
down their throat.
Right.
These other institutions, terrible, where
these people aren't necessarily coming up
for election.
So you talk about things with like the young
kids and with Disney.
Speaker 1: And listen, this guy is at the
forefront of the most important issues.
The woke have to be fought in the halls of
government.
And I mean, look at the this major issue of
Disney.
Disney affirmed in some nominal way gay rights
and so we've got to deal with the woke folks.
But understand this is what Republicans want
to hear.
They want to hear a lot of the same pseudo
fascistic so-called culture war issues presented
in a marginally more serious manner than.
Trump presents them.
Now, that's a separate issue from whether
if a campaign gets going constitutionally,
personality wise, DeSantis has what it takes
to face Trump the different question.
But this is the same old nonsense.
He then talks about how there was an attempt
to impose intersectionality.
Oh, the horror.
The horror.
Speaker 2: Florida Our standards require teaching
all aspects of black history, and we think
it's important.
We also, when we ban critical race theory,
which we were right to do.
Speaker 1: Well, right or wrong, it was nonsense.
Speaker 2: We also required in that same bill
that schools have stories of inspiration about
great Floridians and great Americans from
a variety of different backgrounds.
I want students.
Speaker 1: We need an entire thing about Dana
White and the heroic UFC events he held during
the virus pandemic.
Right.
Speaker 2: To be to be inspired that they
can do well in Florida.
You know as they get old critical race theory
is basically saying some are oppressors, some
are oppressed.
What kind of a message is that sending to
these very young kids?
So so we require all of that.
Speaker 1: And remember, there was no critical
race theory being taught to young kids.
Speaker 2: Our standards in terms of the basic
history with the College Board was trying
to do.
They were trying to impose CRT.
They actually were trying to impose in a black
studies course queer theory.
They were trying to impose intersectionality
and they were trying to impose effectively
neo Marxism.
And so the question is, is that something
you want to do on your own time?
Yeah.
Speaker 1: You're save neo Marxism for the
privacy of your bedroom, please, to.
Speaker 2: Go pursue that.
But for our taxpayers to be supporting that
type of indoctrination, that is not something
that we want to do.
Speaker 1: Now, you might be hearing this
and saying, David, what the hell is Ron DeSantis
talking about here?
Well, he's talking about the things that potential
2024 voters want to hear him talk about.
It's the Glenn Youngkin sort of routine run
on these things, talk about these things all
the time, which aren't really issues and aren't
actually happening.
The topic came up of the Electoral College
and the mandate and power that that winning
the Electoral College gives to a president.
That's very interesting because, you know,
a lot of these small government, supposed
small government conservatives talk about,
you know, we actually should take powers away
from the executive and we they'll just say
whatever they think they need to say.
Yeah, it's hard to remove them, you know,
with the civil service rules and then the
union.
Oh, and sorry.
And this relates to the idea that they bemoan.
They would like it to be easier to fire government
employees.
That's the context here.
Speaker 2: And all the rest.
And well, there is one you know, there is
a proposal that I think a lot of us wanted
to see under the prior administration to do.
Is the.
Speaker 1: Prior administration.
Well, what was that guy's name?
Speaker 2: Schedule F?
So anybody that has any policy role is classified
as a schedule F, and they can be removed by
the president.
The left would litigate that, but I honestly
think we would win on that.
And the Supreme Court and I also.
Speaker 1: Isn't this a great, serious interview,
guys?
Speaker 2: I think it's one thing to have
some type of job rules for the bowels of the
bureaucracy, like your supervisor, what they
can do.
President United States has Article two power.
Who controls the executive branch?
Is it the elected president or is it some
bureaucrat in the bowels of the bureaucracy
that can't?
Speaker 1: Lot of focus on bowels in this
interview fired.
Speaker 2: And so I think push needs have
come to shove on this.
But whoever gets a majority of the Electoral
College is has the right to impose their agenda
through the executive branch.
And what they did with President Trump was
basically try to nullify the election through
not only bureaucratic intransigence, but malfeasance
with the collusion hoax and some of those
things while really.
Speaker 1: Really throwing in everything there.
So, listen, what they're talking about here
is that they're the federal government is
a major employer and there are all sorts of
of jobs and roles within the federal government.
There are some which truly are only bureaucratic
positions.
They are not in any way remotely political.
And then there are jobs within an administration,
in federal government that are obviously political.
The president's cabinet, for example, and
well on down from there.
And the idea was Trump and some Republicans
have gotten the idea that in the middle there
is a ton of nominally bureaucratic positions
that are actually very political.
And so rather than having those jobs be protected
by unions and and mediation and arbitration,
all these different things, they just want
to make the president be able to.
Are all all of these people.
And these are huge numbers of roles.
And of course, if you have the view that these
really aren't political positions and these
are jobs that people depend on in a way that
a secretary of state is not likely to depend
on that job to feed their family, that they
should be protected from a president coming
in and just going replace everybody.
Not to mention in a lot of these jobs, you
really don't want to be replacing people every
few years is the truth.
So this is what they're talking about, making
it easier to fire people.
So, again, a completely deranged interview,
authoritarian, while still pretending that
he's kind of small government.
Framed as a very serious discussion between
legal scholars when it's actually just the
same tired political nonsense with a little
bit of different window dressing.
And quite frankly, if Ron DeSantis decides
to run for president, that I think, is what
the candidacy will be, the same old political
nonsense.
And suppose it culture war issues as a shield
for authoritarianism with slightly different
window dressing.
All of these clips that I've played for you
here will have them on our YouTube channel
at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show,
but also on the Spanish YouTube channel.
So, Rick, what was that, a clip?
Just something glitching start.
You guys hear that?
Oh, my God.
I got to get out of here.
Dear God.
Oh, my goodness.
Okay, let's close everything.
That was really embarrassing.
The Spanish channel.
David Pakman dot com slash Spanish.
Approaching 2000 subscribers.
Let's take a break.
Fix all the technical problems and come right
back.